this one was my stand a paddle race
World Championship which is the third
world title that I ever want this is a
really special paddle for me because I
remember last year was definitely a year
where I had to push you know far beyond
what I was at at the time and it just
reminded me to constantly be kind of
reinventing myself and not to be afraid
to try new things
and growing up you know my mind was
always open to these different things
and I grew up here on Maui which is the
mecca for multiple sports and I think
that's why I'm so excited to be in the
suit of this suit is you know
it might be a little scary but for me
you know since I've grown up with that
open mind
I'm just embracing it I'm so stoked to
have this thing on and hopefully you
know we'll be wearing suits more often
than not I you know found out that I
could always handle a little more than
I've always thought is that you know
work that I had to do to she in that
moment and that moment so pure and it's
so satisfying and it's only last for
like 30 seconds where you truly feel
like you know nothing else exists and
everything that you've done up to that
point is fine and you don't have to do
any more but then after that so 30
seconds ends you realize with more
events coming up my mind completely
switches over to that next event like
it's like alright I won but I have to do
the next one I got to win the next story
each one of these paddles has a
significant story like you know tell
them above my head and you know when I
remember that you know there's a story
behind that
do you want to see me do more cool stuff
check out me windsurfing kitesurfing in
a suit on the GQ channel